president vladimir zelinsky says he's
open to negotiating a potential neutral
status for his country in an interview
with several independent russian news
organizations which the kremlin banned
from publication inside russia zielinski
said his team was carefully studying
moscow's demand for ukrainian neutrality
he said that the issue would have to be
put to a referendum it comes as the
ukrainian intelligence service warns
that russia is trying to split the
country in two
after more than a month of fighting kiev
remains in ukrainian hands though
increasingly scarred by war but even
those whose homes have been destroyed
believe that victory is possible with
enough help
everything depends on how our western
friends help us
we will win if we get lots of help we
will win soon
as it struggles to make advances on the
ground russia has ramped up its
bombardments
much of har heave just 50 kilometers
from the russian border already lies in
ruins it was ukraine's second largest
city now half of its residents have fled
thousands of those who remain have taken
refuge in underground train stations
hiding from russia's heavy shelling
in the besieged city of mariupol the
situation is even more dire food and
water are scarce and locals say they've
had to bury their dead in makeshift
graves
ukraine's president is carefully
considering how to best end the
suffering vladimir zelinski said his
team was studying russia's demand for
ukrainian neutrality and that the issue
would have to be put to a referendum
security guarantees and neutrality
non-nuclear status of our country we are
ready to go for it that's the most
important point it was the main point
for the russian federation that's why
they started this war
on sunday ukrainian authorities said an
agreement had been reached with russia
on a humanitarian corridor out of mary
upon giving residents the chance to try
and reach safety
those who do make it out may well join
the ever-growing number of refugees like
these crossing into romania via ferry
and for the latest on ukraine we're
joined by dwc correspondent fanny vachar
in the western city of la vie fenney
president zielinski is now talking about
a potential neutral status for ukraine
in exchange for security guarantees
would any guarantees for moscow be
credible though
that's a really good question given the
situation here on the ground and all
what ukraine has been through since
february 24th all the bombardments
across the east and the southern but
also northern parts of ukraine and also
here in lev just a couple of days ago so
difficult to answer but also if we just
look back on history there's the minsk
agreement in 2014 which was supposed to
bring an end to the war in the donbass
region that did not happen that minsk
agreement was signed by russia it was
signed by ukraine but this is where real
politik is on the ground right now
instead of bringing peace to donbass
this escalated even further with this
full-scale invasion of february 24th
president zelinski from his perspective
says there's only going to be peace if
russian forces withdrawal the question
is just how far
that wasn't really clarified because he
actually said they should withdraw to
where they were now this could be only
the donbass region but you also make
clear there's not going to be peace
without a ceasefire so a lot of things
that are quite catchy and even if for us
journalists it's so difficult to
translate what the actual
deal breaker would be here just imagine
how hard it will be for these two
negotiation teams the delegations of
russia and ukraine to actually come to
terms to something that they then can
put forward to their audiences which is
ukraine here and russia
in the neighboring country
you were mentioning the donbass region
and those minsk agreements and the
negotiations that broke down they were
seen as a way towards peace
could that be a way out of the war is
sacrificing the dawn bass seen as
potentially the way forward
president zielinski in that 90-minute
interview that he had with russian
journalists he made clear that he's not
going to basically force uh to of course
be retake all russian occupied
territories now the largest chunk of
that is the donbass region having said
that it clearly implies that he may
would want to have a compromise over
that
region which is a very difficult
question he said actually in that
interview how that compromise is going
to be reached but he's putting it out
there as a way to find a way around all
of this and to bring an end to the war
because what he underlined in that
interview as well he wants to decrease
that there's more bloodshed that there
are more casualties and that this war is
is prolonged by such uh by by more
months more weeks to come so yes it is
definitely a central point to the
donbass region but the question really
is whether people will accept that
president zielenski in ukrainian in a
different interview designed for the
ukrainian audience said yesterday that
he definitely wants to have a referendum
about anything that may bring a change
to the territory here and he also said
that he wants to prioritize the
territorial integrity of ukraine so a
lot of conflicting messages there if you
ask me we'll have to see what these
peace talks will bring that are supposed
to start today in turkey
okay dw's fanny pachar in la viv thanks
so much
and after a month of war now many have
been surprised at the strength of
ukraine's defense but the human cost of
the conflict remains high with a number
of both military and civilian casualties
growing by the day
and amid the destruction people are
having to bury their friends and family
in the most difficult of circumstances
dw correspondent amnesia sent us this
story on a slain soldier from a small
village close to the polish border
a house fallen silent
he was just 20 years old
hit by russian artillery on day three of
the war
it took weeks for his family to learn of
his death and bring him home
people from all around came to dimitro's
funeral to honor him
he was a true cossack
and he smiled a lot he was funny
artistic
he always wanted to help everyone
he loved us all so much
are a military family dimitro's sister
said their father is considered by many
a hero of the donbass conflict
it seemed natural that her brother would
choose the same path
dimitro's schoolhouse
his teacher received the news of his
death with a mixture of pain and pride
saw each other for the last time on the
12th of february and he said okay
goodbye we'll never see each other again
and i said to him you can't say that
i ask if his death has scared any of the
young men in the village who may one day
have to face the front lines absolutely
absolutely not it will give them more
courage and strength maybe even make
them angry enough to take on such a
responsibility nobody is afraid it's no
longer 2014 there's a completely
different feeling in western ukraine
we've always seen military service as a
responsibility a duty is a duty
a lesson instilled at a young age here
theirs is not to reason why
the cemetery where dimitro is buried
his grave is visible from a distance and
it seems as if it's the very center of
the town
a tragedy but piled high with flowers
and more than half of ukraine's children
have been displaced by the war with huge
implications for their development and
education some ukrainian teachers are
trying to keep up the school routine
using the internet to teach children
scattered across europe we met a young
school girl who fled to germany but is
still attending classes run from back
home in ukraine
it's eight o'clock in the western german
city of bonn
the first lesson of the day is starting
for nastya habar it's an online lesson
normally she would be in kiev at her
school right now but at the beginning of
march she had to flee ukraine together
with her family because of the war
it is quite important to stay in touch
with teachers and classmates we all need
that in this situation
that way we get to see how all of us are
doing that way everyone knows that i'm
doing well
is giving the lesson
before the war began they could all be
at school together
now most of her classmates are scattered
all over europe
that's why elena teaches them digitally
she's still in kiev
it's dangerous to stay at home
but unfortunately that is not possible
along with her sister and mother has
been placed with a host family in
germany
this gives them security for the time
being
nevertheless like thousands of ukrainian
children the kids are now missing
important lessons at school
that's why they'll soon be enrolled in
germany until then online lessons help
them
i do exercises with them i paint with
them we carve and glue
we make all kinds of artwork
this gives them strength it gives them
courage
and also confidence for the future
thanks for doing the shopping today we
need lots of things for the party nastya
is in germany her classmates in poland
the czech republic and slovenia but her
teacher manages to reach them all